Film Courage: Brian we hear filmmakers say that
filmmaking keeps them out of trouble
or they say "You know this is all I can
do. This is why I do it even though it's
hard at times." Sometimes I wonder is it
really all they can do? Or that's just
what they sort of say to themselves
that's what they want to do. What are
your thoughts on this? Brian Avenet-Bradley, Horror Filmmaker: I'm sure it varies
for each filmmaker I mean for me I can
do other things but what I find happens
is if I don't do something creative and
for me my creativity teams always go
visual so it always goes into movies if
a certain amount of time passes and I
haven't done something I start to go a
little crazy a little stir-crazy
so there's like this drive - for me it's
a drive to tell stories and then
eventually and I write a lot and I write
a lot of stories and usually the story
we end up doing with my filmmaking
partner Lo is usually one that I've had
for a while that I keep coming back to
or won't go away like you won't
sometimes I'll be able to write
something it's kind of done even though
it's like never see the light of day
maybe it's a script or a story or just
an idea I can get it out of my system
and it feels like okay I'm okay but
every now and then there's a story that
they just keep that keep thinking about
it it comes back and comes back and
comes back and usually that's the one
it's like I have to do this one you know
find a way to make it in a format that
other people can see it you know is
there sort of a timeframe for you like
if you're in between projects is there
like a three-month window where if you
don't have something new to work on you
can start to feel yourself slipping so
to speak I mean I'm always like thinking
of ideas so it's like the same flaw
greater than three month window for me
as long as that as long as I'm like
collecting ideas and thinking about
stories and writing it down I'm fine I
think it's like if if it's like going up
to a year and are not actively involved
in making a movie or making some other
creative project which will come to
fruition so other people can see it then
I probably get get the shakes unless
it's like I have to do it you know I
think something uh-huh yeah what do you
start to see yourself slipping into when
you know like you you become bored
easily or how do you know like oh you
know what this is after a while you
learn
this is because I need to start working
on something you know for me it's like
really I just kind of get into a malaise
it's like is it really it's like doing
something creative is kind of what makes
me feel alive and if too much time goes
by and I'm not doing something creative
then it's just I don't know I find
myself kind of sinking into this like
malaise of just life isn't really
working for me and then I'm like what's
wrong and I'm like it kind of hits me
like Oh cuz I'm not doing something
great it's amazingly I forget every time
you know like why am I feeling this way
and then it's like oh excuse I'm not
creatively involved in something
fortunately I have a lot of other things
that I do which are also creative so
that helps me kind of sustaining a
little bit but for me it's like the
projects I'm most passionate about are
the ones that my wife and filmmaking
partner Laurence Avenet-Bradley ("Lo") that we do
together and those are the ones because
it's our project and it's it's a passion
project so we kind of control it from
beginning middle and end so it's very
much like our vision of what we want to
tell and that is to me the most
creatively satisfying is when you can do
a project like that where it's not going
to have too much outside influence that
changes what you're trying to make what
other creative things do you do oh I do
editing so I do editing for a television
series television shows which obviously
involves a lot of creativity I do a lot
of like docu reality type shows which
actually requires you as an editor to be
very involved in story because you're
working with the story people and the
producers to help figure out the story
and develop so it's like it's more than
just cutting something from a script
it's very it really engages you
creatively because you're really working
on figuring out like well how do we tell
the story what is the story
sometimes you're figuring out well you
know what is this you know what is the
story and how do you tell a beginning
middle and end and make it dramatic and
keep people engaged with it it heard an
author speaker this weekend a Brazilian
author and forgive me on her name I'll
put it at the below-the-line part of the
video but she said that when she gets
writer's block and she says it's very
real that she has to do things like go
to museums
just just you know the other creative
things that are not writing do you ever
feel blocked and if so do you have a
ways to get out of it well I definitely
feel like going places like Lo and I
like taking trips and going places we
like to go out to the desert or to the
mountains sometimes up to the beach or
the ocean it's like I get a lot of
inspiration from locations especially on
with movies and it gets a little tricky
sometimes because sometimes I fall so in
love with the location it's hard for me
to imagine not shooting it there but but
they'll be usually a location can be a
really big inspiration for me like I'll
see something and then it starts my mind
going what if what if what if and
there's been places that we've
incorporated in our films sometimes it's
not that exact same location but like an
idea from that location will find its
way into the story something inspired
mice so I find like the best way for me
at least creatively is to find the
inspiration from real life because if
you don't do that then I feel like you
get into a cycle of copying which is
really easy to fall into you mean it's
really easy to look at a movie and go oh
I like that movie but I would have done
something like this with that movie and
then you know you can easily change it a
few degrees and it'd be a new movie but
in essence it's gonna be so built on the
other film that it's not really a new
thing whereas if you can get the
inspiration from life or or stories you
hear from other people like real stories
that happen to them or they know of a
friend something happened a lot of times
that can spark the imagination into
thinking like oh well you know what if
what if that story happened and then
this happened and that happened and to
me that's that's the most fun it's kind
of like taking the inspiration from real
life is location of our character and if
you're filming I'm sure yeah yes as I
would say location for us is almost
always a character and almost every film
we've done I think it's funny cuz this
film dark remains I forget this is the
this is our dark remains a location that
Lawrence lo found as I was writing the
script she fell in love with this like
prison location that was in Rome Gona
which is no longer in existence but it
was a closed prison but they we could
actually go there and shoot and she's
like well you have to add a prison to
the story because it's prison so great
I'm like well there's no way to put a
prison in the story anyway after like
complaining for a while I woke up the
next day and I'm like oh well if this
prison became part of the story like
this it changed everything it made it
better I mean it rippled through and the
prison became such a thing like when it
came out in Japan they're like they they
retitled a ghost prison like you know
none of these things are in the movie
but is they even the prison it's in the
movie and but they like to do this with
clip art and change the graphics when it
goes overseas but they decided they
loved the prison so much the movie title
became ghost prison so definitely like
locations become like a huge thing this
film which was our second film goes to
the needle which they reach out at 6
eeeh I think in Spain that one factor a
factory is a very key location for the
main character and a lot of events take
place in the factory and that became
like a very key part to the film and
once we found the factory we did a lot
of revisions on the script in writing
because the the location inspired us
because I had other things in the script
but once you see the real Factory you're
like oh well this could happen this
could happen and this is there was an
elevator there there's this amazing
freight elevator that was there and that
added like this whole thing with going
between the different floors and and so
I'm like for me it's like locations
including the first one we did freezer
was our first film and this actually
took place on what was the family farm
they spent a lot of time on growing up I
was in Vergania right across the border
from Tinesy and and I spent a lot of
childhood years and weekends and weeks
on this farm and that location was like
it basically was the script because they
basically once I came up with a story
and realized that what's happening here
it like you would go with the characters
here and the characters in the
situation's what would happen
because there are these things in that
location so into bringing your
protagonist your antagonists and you go
what would they do and then based on
being in this environment and then you
basically get scenes and you get moments
and it actually influences the writing
of the script and I find that I don't
know I find that very exciting when your
location can actually be the look when
the location that inspire is the story
can actually be the one that you shoot
at that's the best I mean it doesn't
always worked out because you maybe
can't for practical reasons you did that
location but that's the best case
scenario otherwise whenever you do get
the real location you you kind of have
to embrace it and make changes instead
of trying to fight it to be the location
you don't have because that'll work
against you but location definitely a
character yeah
you